it gives me so much hope and praise just
in life to bring up black news because
the Black History Month you know I like
to take a step back you know go back to
like the Africanism of it all
got my little Africans shirt on and
whatnot listen to a little bit of afro
feet like make me feel connected to the
culture I celebrate like resiliency to
persist through you know and to be an
example of what our people fought for
I'm inspired year-round by black people
I love the extra myths that we kind of
get during February that's not seeing
the rest of the year I celebrate that
culture and like how universal it is and
how similar it is for all black people
Barack Obama Michelle Obama
the Obamas to really exemplify like what
joy and excellence looks like we are
embraced worldwide our culture our music
our style it's about unity and loving
one another I celebrate my father every
February he would have this deck of
cards of influential black people
throughout history he would give us a
card every day to read and he's just
tried like all of his life to make sure
that we know we're important more than
just our skin tone to my parents that
had to face adversity and racism to
raise to half black and half white kids
in the middle of Arizona in the 1980s my
parents who gave me the life that I had
my mom who although is not
african-american has worked her ass off
being there for us trying to understand
the world that we see me going natural
now you know is really from my mother
and her whole outlook on what it means
to be natural and really just getting
back to to the root of it all everyone
who works tirelessly to give me
everything I have today Rosa Parks
Martin Luther King Malcolm X and all
those guys I kind of paved the way for
for all black people Sidney Poitier
being the first black man to ever win an
Oscar I celebrate one of my favorite
actor
maya angelou one of my favorite quotes
is i've learned that people will forget
what you said people will forget what
you did but people will never forget how
you made them feel
and that's something that I try to carry
with me every day I celebrate the music
that has come out of black history the
temptations Aretha Franklin Miles Davis
and Muddy Waters and guys that changed
the game sisters I thought Billie
Holiday and Jimi Hendrix Bob Marley I
will say in the year 2016
you don't need an occasion to celebrate
Beyonce you always celebrate Beyonce
jay-z Solange Kendrick Lamar chance the
rapper was my [ __ ] the chances
incredible artists incredible father
ultimately one of the leaders of our
generation
Spike Lee represents for the black
culture it is such a beautiful way
through film moonlight one of the most
incredible films of our generation I
think the conversation is about what we
believe blackness and black masculinity
to look like was really important you
celebrating blackness in a way that's
like really elevating the conversation
we weren't pigeonhole we put into these
little roles and just made to be side
characters of supporting cast and I
really cannot like about black women you
know like women and what they've done
for culture what they're doing for us
finding strength and being recognized
for their beauty and their talent their
hard work I'm inspired by a woman of
color who are taking strides behind the
camera as directors and producers and
also those women who are in front of the
camera and showing us this dynamic and
diverse world that we live in
[Music]